vous êtes là vous tombez bien j'attends
justement julie et casimir ils doivent
apporter tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
de la peinture mais non c'est pas pour
moi c'est pour monsieur du snob il a
perdu toutes ses affaires d'artiste
peintre alors nous essayons de les lui
remplacé
bonjour françois moment là casimir bravo
tu le premier mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça ça c'est un grand pot d'autres
délicieuses confitures d'offres à ayzac
mais c'est tout commence et tout c'est
par un beau cadeau va donc azimuts tu te
fiches du monde mon vieux lamenta non
pourquoi mais casimir mais nous ne
ferons pas monsieur du snob de quoi se
faire des tartines nous voulons lui
donner de quoi faire de jolis tableaux a
alors tu ne veux pas de ma confiture de
freins et les agneaux casimir nous a
bien je remporte je vais aller la manger
console parfait avec des sardines à
l'huile c'est délicieux
des sardines à livres
france soir oui tu peux venir mais
certainement gély j'arrive à ma campagne
est lourd formidable julie je la
trouvais beaucoup d'objets à je suis
épuisé j'ai été rendre visite à tous les
habitants de l'île j'ai mal aux pieds
notre pauvre mais en tout cas ça valait
la peine ou julie je suis désolé mais il
ya là dedans un certain nombre d'objets
qui ne sont pas du tout pour un artiste
est un jeu gagnant ça doit être très
difficile parce que j'avais tellement
peur d'être en retard n'est pas eu le
temps de vérifier ce qui me donne c'est
pas grave je vais classe et tout ça avec
l'aide des enfants dis moi qu'est-ce que
casimir t'a apporté rien rien au nom il
est reparti chez lui aux victimes et
d'apporter un pot de confiture de
fraises d'une rencontre un artiste
peut-être est-ce que tu imagines un
tableau fait avec de la confiture de
fraises ça je lui dis ce que j'en
pensais mais je crois qu'il a oublié que
c'était déjà prêt pour la peinture
casimir ne fait jamais attention à ce
qu'on lui dit en tout cas messieurs 19
ne va pas tarder et des gens nous les
enfants venez venez
vite il me dit j'ai besoin de vous venez
tous les enfants dans ce panier il y un
certain nombre d'objets il y en a
certains qui sont destinés à monsieur
des clubs qui va recommencer sa carrière
d'artiste peintre vous allez les nommer
d'accord alors soyons
se laver les doigts quand après la
peinture à l'huile parfaitement raison à
celle de l'essence de térébenthine
jeu mais par ici pour monsieur du snob
ça sert pas pour faire de la
peinture non si on mettait de sa femme
par ici
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
fuse ça sert à quoi faisait
ça sert à faire un croquis savait à quoi
ce serait quoi c'est fait avec du
charbon de bois je voudrais par ici
qu'est-ce que ça ça sert à faire vivre
la musique et je croyais que monsieur
dans des concerts mais chez 10,9 en aura
besoin pour nom alors je n'ai par la
voilà comment c'est fait une toile
voilà c'est ça navigue
parfaite très bien gris tiens je te
confie
ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est je
suis fier quand on a fini lui donc je le
mets par ici pour mâcher du snob nous
ça ne vient pas pour la peinture
ensuite ceux ci
[Musique]
s'appelle des couteaux
voilà
ceci
c'est de la gouache la gouache et de la
teinture te montre
c'est la peinture à l'eau évidemment qui
est aussi la peinture à l'huile pour la
caisse que nous avons encore bien voilà
on arrive
[Musique]
avec le petit à petit non
toi tu en fait un parfait et bien voilà
je crois qu'on a on a tous passé en
revue merci les enfants à les jouer
maintenant julie je serai peut-être bien
de faire avec ça un paquet cadeau ce
serait plus présentable ah oui oh oui me
suis dit mme baril c'est trop de temps
pour samy rien bonjour m de shenzhen
bojan messi 10 9 je n'apprends une
merveilleuse nouvelle est ce vrai chers
amis que grâce à votre initiative et
pouvoir reprendre la peinture eh oui si
ce n'est tous les cadeaux de vos amis
aucun je suis vraiment
faire quasiment
non parlons pas ce nom ça n'avait rien à
voir v avec la teinture il voulait vous
offrir un poteau que ce pinceau est
suppléé à je pouvoir faire des oeuvres
inoubliable avec tout cela j'espère que
vous nous les montre à même bien entendu
à il n'y a qu'une chose que je vous
laisserai mais ce sont les tubes de
peinture oui j'ai trouvé une nouvelle
matière plus extraordinaire encore cette
nouvelle matière de quoi faire des
heures absolument fantastique mais c'est
passionnant monsieur 10,9 peut-on savoir
quel set mais qu'il la confiture de
fraises je le peins plus qu'à la
confiture de fraises c'est merveilleux
mais au fait cher ami mais toujours pas
dit quel est ce cadeau stupide que vous
le faire
casimir un cadeau j'ai oublié
[Musique]